Face it. Unless you like kicking puppies and smacking babies,...
...firing someone is not pleasant.
The person doing the firing doesn't sleep well night before.
They know it must be done, but often don't know quite what to do or say.
What Do I Say?
The best way to tell somebody is to just directly tell them.
"We've decided to make a change."
Or, "It's not working out, and we're going to need to let you go."
People already know when a relationship is not going well,...
...so most of the time they are expecting it.
When Do I Say It?
Not on a Friday, if you can help it.
When you fire someone at the end of a week,...
...you sentence them to two days, Saturday and Sunday, of self-torment.
By releasing them into the world at the beginning of the week,...
...they may actually have the time to make a few phone calls or set up a meeting or two.
What Do We Do After I Say It?
If they want to talk, listen to them.
Don't argue, don't get defensive,...
...and don't feel that you have to explain or justify your decision.
You are the one in control.
It is very helpful to anticipate their questions in advance.
That way, you can put all the information in writing.
After you answer their questions,...
...simply give them the memo explaining what you have just told them.